thought of a crucial victory for you
this uh wasn't easy at all and in fact
it was a complicated situation it felt
like you were on the defensive side as
we were looking and analyzing your game
but in the end it was that end game and
that mistake by Anna that uh turned the
tides in your favor how are you feeling
right
now when when was I on the defensive
side we thought that with that Rook on
E7 and when you played Bishop to C4 with
thought that you were going to go for
Bishop to D3 like right somewhere at
this
point not here at this point after
Bishop to
C4 we thought that you will go for this
and we weren't really sure how to assess
it we thought that you were on the
defensive in this one no I thought I can
easily make a dve if I put a bishop on
F7 and I just give up my other Bishop I
can she ever win this and that was
question we were trying to find whether
you can actually do that or
not well okay she has to go King h8
right bop C4 yes A3
A3 ah you think I don't have time for
this we couldn't find a way how you
actually give up the pawn for the light
for the dark scare
Bishop ah but okay Bishop F
[Music]
two yaser I'm looking at you yeah yeah
yeah remember how we got it you were
saying that yes yes yes yes in okay Rook
E4 Bishop F7 now and Rook a no Rook E2
Bishop D4 how did we get we had we we we
checked ourselves before I can attack
right Bishop D5 yes after uh Rook to
E4 yeah yeah I just thought I cannot win
this and I thought okay in the other
position at least I can I don't know
what they were analyzing okay forget
about forget about it yes so Queen to D4
and this Rook takes E6 you guys got this
position she goes H4 H5 if she goes H4
this is pretty much over at this point
well I thought I'll go Bishop H2 and
then maybe I can play I know I cannot
win this but uh so this I was very upset
because I know I was winning after that
Rook exchange sacrifice and then like I
just things got out of hand at some
point I don't know which point
think at any point I I don't know where
I just completely gave it up I didn't
see this knight h8 move I don't know if
that's the best move ier but I I don't
know what exactly my mistake was I kind
of got low on time I just kind of got
confused with all this pins absolutely
but still she was the one that made the
last mistake and you got the full point
now you're getting closer uh to those
Podium positions how are you feeling
going into the last couple of rounds
oh yeah this was a crucial victory for
me for the standings um obvious I don't
think I'm fighting for first three
because I already played um well okay
first two I already taken I already
played Alice so that's completely out of
my hand so I think realistically I'm
probably fighting for fourth maybe if I
get lucky fighting for third but uh not
a lot of Hope for the podium this year
guys any questions for no just our
congratulations for beating a a rival of
many many years Anna and and uh well uh
two more games uh we'll see you
T thank you absolutely as we have